i mean give me a s give me a six who's
got a great personality
i'm good
yeah yeah what's a good what's a good
personality to you guys
let me not say just good personality
just
the right qualities that i desire in a
woman what are those
um
they're just they're the same things
that men talk about all the time
cooperativeness
um
so besides i think it's gonna be a good
mother besides the things that men talk
about all the time what are the ones
that are different for you
what do you mean
you said what do you like specifically
yeah um i like a woman who likes to
learn
okay like i like a woman who has a mind
to want to learn new things
that's what i like
yeah um so because i'm always reading
something i'm always researching
something i'm always doing something and
to have like
fruitful conversation it's a thing for
me yeah yeah i want to be able to
intellectually yeah i want to have a
fruitful conversation with somebody
because i may be sexually attracted to
you and we may you know [ __ ] each
other's brains out or whatever but
after that i want to know that if we
have a conversation it's going to be
fruitful we can talk about politics yes
you know i mean we can talk about
religion or we can talk about whatever
it is do you know what i mean we can
talk about the world and social issues
yeah would you guys date a feminist hell
no yeah yeah
are you not do you consider yourself a
feminist
uh
no
oh no
not not modern-day feminists no i mean i
believe equality for men and women but
i wouldn't call myself a feminist today
no but you'd date one
i would be opposed to it it depends what
kind of feminist she is yeah that's what
yeah that's what i don't know depends on
the men hating feminism oh let's say
let's say let's say she's not
aggressive
let's say she's nice enough right cute
enough nice enough whatever like nice
person yeah but
she believes in like
you know the feminist ideology
so okay give me some examples um
are not paid the same as men which isn't
true yeah that's not true
um
let's see women heard that i'm like what
well it's just like a certain
lo i meet a lot of really nice people
that just have like a low level disdain
for men but they're really like nice
like people people yeah to be around or
whatever but i just i noticed it's very
common and girls that i meet so i'll
tell you what i think yeah what my kind
of
do they have a disdain for men yeah and
it's it's subtle a lot of the time it's
not it's not right out in your face it's
like very subtle um
um for example if i if i mention like a
men's rights rights issue a lot of times
their first reaction is well well women
what about me
it's just like a low level
my kind of um
my kind of approach with it and that's
not saying that i would choose somebody
off that
you know i think likelihood i probably
wouldn't like for long term
but i kind of see it as like
their kind of mentality and thinking is
a result of the climate they've grown up
in so it's kind of like you know anybody
any of these if anyone who's dated a
white girl if you've met her
grandparents they probably didn't like
you for that very reason
right
and their grandparents were probably
racist but then they're racist
personally attacked
well i'm just saying my grandparents
my grandparents are very nice thank you
no it's true but like
i think it's more like you're talking
generally i'm talking general i'm
talking in general and i think
i don't hold it against them
because they are a result of their
generation like if they were born today
i don't think they've had they'd have
the same views right so i think with
quote-unquote extreme feminists yeah me
and extreme feminism get along like i'll
be honest especially in my industry i've
clashed with a lot of people
i love creative types i've clashed with
a lot of people yeah um
but
i've had it where
i'll be honest there's a girl that i
dated
recently where
she used to be that kind of girl
she used to be that kind of girl we used
to have debates like every week right
and then we started dating because not
because she came out that mindset but
then she came out of that mindset and
came to more
actually aware of what's actually going
on right
and then that
lined up for us does that make sense
so but she was probably debating you
because she was attracted to the fact
attracted to the fact that you
weren't agreeable with her maybe and
it's so funny all her friends turns out
i know
i'm just having a conversation with
someone about this how it's like it's
like fighting it's almost like
attractive when i get argues with you a
little bit yeah
like a little bit no i know women like
that yeah like it's true like you know
someone who's not especially a man not
afraid to say his mind
even if it's doesn't and i'll never you
know if someone asks my opinion i'm
going to give my honest opinion right
um i want to ask you a question okay
what do you think of
men who
strongly proclaim themselves to be
feminist oh i can't
i can't oh my gosh no i don't
i won't give him the time of day tell us
what
because i'm [ __ ]
because i just don't consider myself a
feminist and i think that whole ideology
is just toxic and i just don't agree
with it and i feel very very strongly
about this yeah so i think that a guy
that has the complete opposite ideology
as me
would just be like right like
i just don't believe him
i feel like i feel like they're
disingenuous
um i'm doing it to get you
didn't need to get vagina yeah most of
them i think
that's like the first thing you could
tell me to like want to get yeah yeah
yeah like i went on a date with a male
feminist then he asked me to pay half i
was like i see where you were
i see what you i see
yeah well and then it was crazy because
he wanted to go back and i said no and
he got mad i was like where am i right
i was like
no
sir you just asked me if i believe in
population control
i just remember thinking like this is
you were talking to the wrong [ __ ]
right now
like
i was just thinking like he probably
thinks this is going like well yeah
because i'll i'll talk like i'm a chit
chatter right you know
and i'm agreeable so i i just kind of
sit there
yeah
he's like doing well here
that's how he's gone oh
that's probably more dangerous for guys
because they just don't know where they
stand with you
yeah well that's why i don't like
there's a lot of guys that like i'll
start like talking to and then i realize
that they're they're super laughed and i
just can't it's yeah
i couldn't like be with a girl who's
like really far left it's weird because
like i
if you ask me 10 years ago
i would have said
that i'm left wing
but now i wouldn't say that but that's
not because my because my values have
changed it's because the goal posts have
changed yeah like what's now considered
left wing is like
you know like for example
i don't know i remember seeing this
thing a few years ago where like people
who were pedophiles were trying to get
involved the lgbtq community because
they were like oh well it's i was born
this way so that's normal there was a
whole there was a whole temple on board
with that there was a whole ted talk on
it was that yeah on why on why
pedophilia is a sexual choice oh
i will never be on board yeah
so it's like so there's something as
well like
oh one thing i've definitely clashed
with people in my industry when they say
um when they say black people can't be
racist
i'm like that's nonsense anyone can be
racist like it may affect people
differently
what do you think racism is then
because that's that's the question that
i always say when when people say that
like what do you think racism actually
is i think it's an illusion
[Music]
i think it's an illusion just because
you see all the people that are racist
right now
it was taught to them
it's true it was taught because let's be
honest like 500 years ago those people
ain't alive yeah so
growing up you had to
say something to your kids for
racism to still go on that's true
all these mps that are racist
like they are they are the the white
kids that that their parents were like
listen you're gonna go out there well
their parents might have certain
conversations in in front of them to
make them think that
certain things are okay so you know how
some you hear people say oh what's
normal for you no normal for them is
not liking black people yes you know
what i'm saying yeah so but i think all
people are race prejudice to some degree
do you think they're race prejudice or
do you think they're
by race bias yeah like
everyone has racial bias to some degree
you can't you can't grow up in the
western world
and not have any kind of rights we're
biased to some degree we're biologically
predispositioned to categorize people
yeah yeah
yeah
it's because your brain can't process
like and it's kind of happens even when
um like if i if i meet a girl like i
kind of want to see is she is she super
feminist is she super like and that's me
categorizing her you know where did she
grow up do we grow up in similar or
different you know
areas because i think institutional
racism is when you have that that
conversation yes i think institutional
racism
is a thing i think individual racism
is nothing to me like if a guy if i go
into the shop now and the guy serving me
for i was a n-word yes
how is that adversely affecting my life
well that's my point as in like there
could be races but it can it impact it
can impact you differently like
depending who's doing it right so these
officers right so that's an ins so the
institution yes it's a thing
but
crazy is that your dog she's fine yeah
when
people say
the black people can't be racist i think
that's what they mean they what the i
think what i think they mean is that we
don't have an institution we don't have
the power to enforce
that type of thing and i think that's
what they mean and and i
i agree with that like me being racist
to you
will probably have very little impact
compared to you being racist to me if
you were like
maybe if we were in public or i don't
know or whatever they're not going to
adversely impact pearl's life by calling
her something no because pearl's still
going to wake up tomorrow do our
podcasts and you know get things done
but when you have the power to influence
her yeah you had an army and you didn't
like pearl because of what she looked
like yeah and it's a problem i agree
like it's definitely a problem
i think that was the argument they were
saying that racism is prejudice plus
power
which i understand to some degree but
then i think i see racism as a behavior
and it's just you're discriminated on
someone because of the color of their
skin
anyone can do that
any yeah anyone can do that anyone can
pre-judge someone based on the color of
their skin how do you guys feel about
things like affirmative action
um
i understand i don't know if you guys
have it here we don't it's in the u.s
can you can you can you define exactly
what you mean before we um when i think
of affirmative action i think of like
quotas
um for example i could even think of one
with women so i worked in a sales like
copier role and it was very male like i
was the only girl in the office
and um they would always try to get
girls to work there but it was a
terrible job so of course
i think the best person for the job
should get the job always right yeah i
think the reason why affirmative action
exists specifically in america is
because there was a huge time where it
doesn't even matter if you're the best
person or not if you're black you're
just not getting the job you know it's
like
you could be better than the white dude
but we ain't gonna hire your black ass
you know i mean like that's what was a
time in america for a very long time so
i understand why it exists i agree i
think yeah go on no no no i um
my parents are both in the corporate
world right
and
you know they've you know rose to like
partner level et cetera et cetera and
all this
and it's like if you had a team
like a sales team
if there was a black individual on the
team you knew they were the best one
and because if they weren't the best one
they wouldn't be on that team
right there's a different standard
because they had to work harder to get
there because people have their own
biases
so if if for example
if a white man is hiring
is he going to hire the nigerian
immigrant
who has the same standard as
the next white fella right who grew up
down the road from him right his natural
biases are going to go there and we all
have natural biases so which is why i
think there is a good argument to
have
to make the people at the top diverse
because it means that more people get to
exercise their biases does that make
sense
but okay
there is a because we do have unnatural
biases it's not necessarily a level
playing field all the time which is why
there is i think some validity to
affirmative action but i don't like
quotas
i don't think
if i have a company and i'm filling
positions i'm all about the bottom line
so i'm taking the best person i don't
care what color creed they are
because that makes sense